contrary to popular belief
i don't know
how to take eyeliner off well
this has happened before
i remember i remember you showed up once
and it was from
way worse though this yeah i was doing a
uh i did a shoot for cloak and that we
did this whole like like
dia de la huerte kind of shoot and this
we're not gonna do their troy episode
um i don't have any objections to not
just a troy episode but it's just a
detroit eyeliner
troy's adventures with makeup
oh man there's been many misadventures
with makeup have you ever done drag
anybody
i have never i i don't even know that
i've done i've ever had makeup on beyond
the
powder the obligatory powder from tv
cameras yeah exactly yeah
that's the the um like press interview
type uh
makeup i think that's the only that i've
ever
um
have you
what's that
have you ever have you ever
had have you ever done drag
i've never done drag no no i don't think
i've got the uh i've got the hips for it
i don't think i'm on any other level
it's critical it's critical no i don't
think it is
i will say this i would i firmly believe
that there would be less misogyny in the
world if everybody did drag once
well because that shit's hard
to limit you know i think there'd be a
lot i think that that's an interesting
sentence structure
in the shoes of someone else right yeah
yeah exactly there'd be a whole lot
yeah i feel like there's a lot of
countries where it's mandatory that you
do like you know two years of of
military service yep
i think specifically in the united
states and the anti-capitalist and you
mike bithell is going to just love this
i'm ready i'm ready it should be
required a matter of fact i feel like
what we could do is we say hey we would
just like to the a lot of countries do
like we will pay for your college if you
go to the military
pay for your college
if you go work in retail or the food
industry
food service industry
if we did that
that's what a lot of people do anyway
right in order to make their way through
those like that was how i put myself
through uni yeah sure most most people
that but there's like this weird you
know
level of people that that don't
and i think i just think that like
everybody who goes to a restaurant would
be like
yeah we can wait 15 minutes no no it's
okay you're busy it's as opposed to this
was iced tea
yeah
i think i would say by the way to ruin a
business meeting with me is to be rude
to wait i have i have turned down
projects based on people who are rude to
wait is that what happened with us
that's why we don't work together yeah
you're a rude toy
i feel like you don't need to dangle
uh
a
subsidized college education
uh
i think it's just like you forfeit the
right to be an [ __ ] to a waiter if
you've never worked sure as a waiter
like you don't need to
complicate it
oh we've lost
i'm still here i'm still here i'm just
gonna go and try and find some
headphones so that the
poor bastard has to cut the audio on
this doesn't have to like have your echo
and everything so just give me a second
didn't i send you headphones what what i
don't understand sorry i sent careful me
try i'm going to find some
i'm going to find some i'll go find some
i'll be right back
i um let's talk about him i had i have
your i have your mic that that i got uh
here i hooked it up and
it i wasn't sure if it was a bad cable
or something wrong with the mic but
every time i used it people would go
you sound garbled something's off
and so
it's
on a mac
that's a yeah
so that's that that's the problem is is
that uh uh
elgato is great not endorsed but i mean
i've good relationship with him but i
haven't seen this show is not endorsed
uh but yeah i prefer pc uh to to to work
with stuff
uh i tried it on a mac and it just
didn't necessarily work right so was it
the same thing where it sounded like the
signal was busted like they kept saying
it sounds like like the kind of thing
when there's a bad cable and there's
interference on the line
um and i remember thinking that's very
odd but
so just know know that it wasn't
rejected i know you felt very
disturbed i felt rejected yeah that's
the way i look today what's that
liverpool football club thank you you
ever just turn a camera on and see your
hair no you both have like organically
perfect hair all the time that's the
first time anyone has ever said that
about my hair and i don't imagine you
put any time into your hair and i think
it looks that way everywhere i put zero
time into my hair and i don't think
anybody could ever look at troy's hair
and go that's just naturally like that
that's just natural i think it's it's a
style this is the style my head is
exploding guys and it's it's i i i look
like i like it if you push a lever down
the hair comes out it's this is this is
uh i don't know what i'm doing with my
life
and i feel like i i mean i i got gussied
up last night that's true
um
it was a lot of fun raised twelve
thousand dollars for ablegamers
not me personally yeah for koyak
that was fun
yeah
it is so impressive it's i've only done
one episode and it is
it is a creative cool thing yeah man and
they i gotta give them a shout out ethan
first of all directed that and and he
crushed it zach who's who's the show
creator is just
dm'ing essentially his ass off or gmming
i guess in that sense
um everybody was on there um
was was incredible finally got to meet
markiplier
markiplier i feel like i say his name is
yeah
i don't know he saw it by having a weird
invented name so you're fine yeah
you might mike biffle um mike bethel
austin winton i pretty much call
everybody by the name that siri calls
them
austin
mine mine's alana pierce it's she's
actually okay that's not bad it's not
too bad
um sorry [ __ ] what's going to say though
elena well alan a lot of americans call
me elena elena
elena
or atlanta probably more often than
alana
atlanta
you also were the uh featured guest of
uh the kiwis
yeah uh you showed up there a bunch of
times sure i'm so excited to see and
still more than anyone else i'm still
really i'm really excited to see more of
uh solace solace man
me too especially because like you and
roger together like i i love roger so
much he's just such a good dude he is
looking forward to seeing it under the
dictionary good dude is a picture of
roger yeah like just so nice you know
just genuinely nice unbelievably good
human um anyone who doesn't know him he
plays uh arthur morgan in uh
red dead too but i think he he was a
theater actor to begin with
touring the theater
is the only correct word for those
situations
and like he did all over europe so they
were doing like germany and prague and
and
this traveling roadshow of shakespearean
plays and
he's just one of those quintessential um
[Music]
yeah like he's a theater cat through and
through and and just cares about of the
the work as they would say
and uh he's he's just he's brilliant
remember you shouted him out
i think he was here on this show
you know many episodes ago you made a
comment that i hadn't really thought
about before of
him recording red dead
like you know
an hour at a time essentially over like
a five-year period you know where it's
just so split up and having to get back
to that place and get back to that
character i remember that anecdote but
ended up talking to him about it and
they also recorded it so out of order in
that instance
so think about doing an open world game
over eight years not five years eight
years yeah and
you are okay remember that thing that we
did six years ago we were talking this
person completely rewritten that and the
characters now this and just like
yeah you even have a concept of a
character rock and he does have a
character up he has an awk like how do
you even huge does that mean that at
that point i i
i've
got a little taste uh working on
stray gods has given me a little bit of
a taste of a mini mini mini micro
version of that where
we'll
record a song over many weeks
because there's so much content wow and
for one song oh no i know how that works
yeah because it's super there's some
songs that are just massive yeah massive
everybody's involved like the finale is
huge
yeah so
so the result of which is
um every time i tried to like explain
okay so here's where the the character
is and this and
i'd usually get this glazed eye
like i this is too much information it's
actually not healthy
tell me how many clicks before i start
faster and louder please yeah and and
and even troy would give me [ __ ] like
i'd get i'd get the look of like
you're you're not actually helping right
now and so it made me think effective
it makes you realize that sometimes
really effective directing is to is to
de-cloud their mind and just
and and and and but then also
and that's why i was asking about red
dead and do you know
if this would be the case there that
the only way that could work is
essentially that whoever is directing
those sessions they have to really know
what the [ __ ] they're doing in order to
guide him and
he has to be able to
trust
that
i don't know who does the the vo
directing it it just seems impossible to
burden him with having to know how all
those pieces fit together right i mean
he couldn't have access to that
information no yeah not not uh first of
all it's not even the vo direction but
it's also the pcap direction right so
you're true you could be potentially
talking about um
actors could have changed it's all i
mean i don't even know i i think about
the amount of stuff that changed over
how baby
that changed over you know two and a
half years i mean we were like five
years of production for last was part
two
and um
does pcap get messed up if you like lose
or gain weight
because the way you walk changes that's
why i asked yeah like your physicality
changes
singing in the recording with the lycra
suits if you've er
everyone's got titties
[Laughter]
there's the that's the title
we've had a feat episode now we got
titties
um i uh i
when i started doing the last of us i
was i was really really thin
uh and i decided i was gonna get in the
gym and start working out and started
working on my fitness and my health
and like i quit smoking and all that
and uh i asked the guy because we were
doing custom suits and i said hey man
i've been working out you know i just
want to make sure that my suit
uh is okay it's gonna it's gonna make it
i'm not gonna like you know he goes bust
out of it
i mean yeah he goes it's spandex man i
think you're fine
it's the dream no you split those pants
right you start towards the end yeah i
went to point like this and it went
and i was like
that has to be like the peak of
masculinity like i feel like that's what
men
that's like men dream about busting oh
okay oh all righty then well swords are
busting out of the street
just [ __ ] strong and also i picture
saving women from castles i think those
are the two
most masculine dreams you can ideally
both simultaneously i think yes is there
one in the same dream manhole see i
think of ripping a suit you get it you
get us a lot of you
guys
like a male ally
it goes to the uh chris farley tommy boy
uh fat guy in a little suit is where i
think of like splitting the suit to me
as a statement of masculinity implies
like this conan physique but i there's a
much easier way to achieve it is
the point i'm driving at that i don't
know
represents
the masters
you have to be yeah you're very
confident that you're hitting that
problem from the right direction
[Laughter]
man but so wait so then to the question
though like how how beholden is the only
way that that works in a red dead case
that that the director or directors
are
just
like you just can only trust that they
are guiding you as an actor
i it seems unfair to ask otherwise is
why i've never worked for rockstar so i
can't speak to their process i have no
idea who did their direction my guess
would be that it was someone internal
but i could be wrong
um
the
the reality is is that it's always trust
they are trusting it i've talked about
this before it's it's a commerce of
resources if they give you a whole bunch
of resources
what did you just run away with
so i had myself muted because he was
playing with this sheep that's a squeaky
toy
and so we want to hear that squeaking
more than me
and then ran away with it which means
he's going to gut it it means it is
going to be torn apart he's going to
murder this calm kong toys are great
because they're like he does love a kong
toy but i worry that we give him so many
that she's going to get back no no no no
no just the rubber ones they don't have
to have a treat in them just something
there's one there's one on the floor it
looks like a carrot it's very kong is
the only thing that canvas doesn't
destroy inside of three households on
the subject of like food stuffs and and
what is that to the side alone i've been
waiting wondering a couple of calls it's
not like it is a nugget right oh my
nugget it is a nugget context please can
we have some comments um it's a
travis scott mcdonald's collaboration
nugget
um that was bought for me for a
valentine's day present okay uh it's
worth a lot of money which is
the most bizarre thing about it
naturally bought partly as a joke but
it's a pillow
that is uh a nugget which i feel like
really values my beautiful statues over
here just much more highly when you have
a nugget i have a follow-up question
that is the
placement
look it's a statement it's very
difficult to figure out where the [ __ ]
to put that thing
in there
no because it looks like even more
ridiculous on your bed and it's it's
like a very hard fabric
right so it'd have to be one of those
pillows that depressed women use where
they put them on the bed in the morning
and then take them all off actually to
sleep on at night and i'm not trying to
be about that like wait hold on
excuse me i love my decorative pillows
yeah i'm pulling out the notepad this is
interesting
is it a long cane poly uh where
i think about it every goddamn morning
every time i do that i think about a
long game polly when i'm just gonna have
one of these boards i'm gonna wake up
and be like michael douglas and snap and
just stab those things
exactly do you do you feel like you're
undoing my point
no decorative pillows equal depression
no they
it's true but it's also um
there was a study that linked uh an
increase in the amount of pillows you
have on your bed to depression um i
believe it's gone don't doubt that you
could draw those lines but we talked
about this before it's something small
that i can control right so
if i start my my day and i make up my
bed
there was a easy accomplishment it was a
task it's a it's a pattern and i feel
like i have
uh started my day off in a productive
way and instantly it transforms the way
that your bedroom looks because like
that's my my mom always told me so you
want to look like your room is clean
start with making your bed and it will
be the biggest improvements the largest
piece of furniture in there hopefully
um so i i will always make my bed and so
i do like that here's the here's the
really neurotic part
i will make my bed drives pam crazy i
will make my bed
right before i go to bed
because does that imply that it's
getting feel of everything kind of late
i i don't i don't like to lie in bed
for a long time before i go to sleep yes
sure
you're a sheep tucker as well you want
me no i'm not i'm not a tucker i'm not
ashamed i don't know i put sheets on the
bed i don't i dislike sheets so heavily
that i just sleep under a blanket
a mattress
no no no no no just under a blanket i
don't sleep under a sheet
sleep like under do they
yeah i do the same thing i want that to
be kind of like the same thing this is
the one i sleep between two mattresses
like a sandwich that's my approach
i'm just interested in all of
that we're going to talk about we've
talked about titties
spoken we could have spoken about the e3
things that are happening but we said no
what e3 is not happening
well is there e3 fair amount of stuff
that's
happened capcom like devastated me
yesterday what did uh
capcom um
okay so they i like the start of it i
was like all i want to see is
dragonstone it's all i want to see i
know i'm not going to see it but it's
all i want to see and then they cut to
dragon's dogma 10th anniversary and they
just say it's been 10 years since
dragon's dogma
i was so [ __ ] excited seeing the
words dragons dogma and then they were
like tell me why i worked on that game
why i love dragons dogma i don't i don't
know what
that's why it's it's got its own series
now too right they're doing an animated
series is that right yeah and i think
there's a dragons dogma online that is
only available overseas
uh i see dragon's dogma as as oh okay
did you kill it he's very excited you
killed the sheep didn't he okay you
gutted the sheep oh boy boy
good boy he barked at somebody yesterday
my only concern with him was that he'd
be a useless guard dog and it's the
first time that i think i've ever been
with him and i would have been
noticeably uncomfortable and i like so i
would have changed my body language he
barked at him he pulled out the german
shepherd i was like good stuff
confirmed all right we're good yeah the
dude like ran away he was like okay
excellent job
now dragons dogma i feel like
like it surprises me that more souls
players don't really enjoy it because it
is very difficult but i think it's also
just like the way that that world
creatively changes i feel like it has a
very compelling story outside of the
romance mechanics
um
there's stuff that i want to talk about
that i can't even talk about because it
would be spoilers very big fan of dragon
stop i would love to see a second one
and
really hoped for it but there is a
stream on the 16th so maybe we'll see
something could also see
final fantasy uh remake part two coming
maybe on the same day at the same time
so crazy
yeah
but i did want to ask about four solas
troy um you kept saying that it was like
a
uh
tight or or fast tight thriller
thriller yeah there's a lot of shorts
and also i understand if you can't
answer that so
there was like keeley wanted to get is
like we had this whole long calls like
let's talk about what what things we
want to discuss on so it's everyone gets
up there we know what we're talking
about and then you get three minutes and
it's just it's not keeley's followers
just the nature of the program it's kind
of like sure we always making sure it's
like did i say the things that i thought
i was going to say
and i said
at one point for the last of us i was
like it's because of the fan
that's sick
it's like because of the fan
single person
with 10 million copies
i'm happy i'm happy to be that guy yeah
i'm an idiot
um
and so uh it's nice to feel personally
thanked for the record
finally right like i said buying last of
us games every five
let's let's let's not talk overall he's
a guest on the show austin we need to
show respect
uh
no i i seed i yield the floor
this was the
i think i said this i hope i don't know
diamond phillips um
luda there was a story that one of my
first thing that i did was a pilot that
didn't get picked up
um
this was i feel like the first time that
we started seeing um
the effects of covid impacting the
industry
and
there were two two projects that that
started right at the the very beginning
of of covet and one of them was uh
medium oops and the other one was uh
fort salas and so like i have my meeting
with those guys at dice
and then fort solace was like right
after where he's like hey i wanted to
see you at dice but i couldn't and i
have this opportunity for you to see if
you'd be down for it
and the thing that got me on it was him
saying he's like we're going to be very
very focused on this we're going to have
the fidelity
of a aaa title but we just want to make
sure that we're really focused on our
resources and where we put that because
i think a lot of times the tendency is
to be like we have to compete with aaa
and they understood it's like ue5 is
giving us a lot of resources that isn't
that was not previously available to a
lot of developers so what does it mainly
give us well it mainly gives us graphics
and physics
and then our core mechanics we keep very
simple and we allow us to be able to
build these great big environments and a
lot of them so that people can explore
those but then keep the gameplay
very very focused um
and i think it's gonna end up being i
don't want to speak out a term but i
think they're talking probably five to
six hours is probably where it's going
to be very focused i love that that's
right i live for that kind of game
yeah
especially as a horror experience
i would say because a horus but and i
said dead space but just because of and
the problem is especially after looking
at the cluster protocol
that that feels like dead space where
you're fighting these [ __ ] creepy
things the thing that i was wanting to
evoke and when james tinsdale the studio
head we're talking about dead space is
the feeling you had playing dead space
where
you just would be going down a hall
i mean
nothing happening you're just in the
space
but as you explore there's just this
constant reminder
through sound effects through lighting
but just through feel that there is
something [ __ ] up that's you're in the
midst of um and then moon was such a
great you know your friend duncan jones
man just one of the most concise simple
movies there were a few that you could
see duncan's influence across the whole
100 like because there was the um the
the new one from the uh well i'm
forgetting this um strategy game so in
in the cold base building they they just
announced like a clone space station
game
why am i forgetting yes i know i don't
remember the name of the game either we
got a few strategy games actually we got
um i was gonna i was gonna ask like why
do we think sci-fi horror has clicked
this because it was noticeable in the in
the key thing that was everybody's six
in a row i feel like it's a covert thing
do you think it's just like we're all
soul mates that's where we are right now
well like
covet is sci-fi horror
like
in theory that's how it was when it
started out it's sci-fi horror and so it
just i think it just blew up to be that
way interesting
plus it's been a while
since i lost sci-fi horror like since i
lost dead space the interesting theory
i've heard is that like this is like if
you were just starting your career when
dead space came out and you were like
that's awesome i want to make that
you've had enough time to get into a
creative leadership role that's the best
that's absolutely
we're seeing those people who were just
like right at the start of their careers
blown away by dead space and then we're
like you know that's the one i'll make
if i get a chance and those people are
starting to get into leadership roles
where they can kind of push themselves
there's always that like
stratigraphy to
things happening you know where it feels
like
it's sort of like the the more crude
analogy is like when you bang your
fingernail and then over a month that
like black mark is making its way to the
front of the nail like there's always
this kind of
this slow
this
slow time lag like i i see it with music
right now where
a lot of the taste makers in the in the
music world are
are
you know
they grew up in the 80s
on the kind of heyday the the first
heyday of the world of analog synths so
90s and early 2000s that stuff was all
relegated to being super dated and out
of fashion but now that the
the maturity has been reached by the
people who were growing up then
you see the stranger things of the world
going no we're just gonna
unapologetically do this and so it seems
like you can always kind of guess i
remember actually once
one of the best advice i ever got in a
from a from a composer
was he said when you're starting a new
project with a new director look up what
was the biggest
like songs on the radio when they were
like 15. uh what are yours then austin
well as someone who did not in any way
listen to the radio when i was 15
um my answer i'm also not a good example
for that question either as made evident
by the t-shirt that i'm wearing right
now s club 7 baby if there's anything
that i've learned since starting to make
a video game full-time it's that i for
sure want to make a horror game there
are so many instances where i'm like
what if it was creepy like i keep doing
it all the time and i think it's
majora's mosque i think it's the time
that i played majora's mask because it's
not completely horror but i was so
unsettled by it and still was in love
with it when i was a kid and i feel like
it like informed me being like oh but
spooky moon crash on planets
i think it's an important thing to like
get out of your system as well like to
an extent like we like volume was like
basically like every i was a big male
gear solid known as a kid and that was
my game where i just made metal gear
solid vr options basically and i had a
lovely time
and it was well enough received and i
got to go on to the next thing it kind
of i kind of needed to make that game so
i could make
other games after it so i think it's i
think it's an essential i think it's a
stepping stone for a lot of people when
you find yourself in that creative
leadership role where you can like
decide on the project you want to make
at that point doing the thing you've
been thinking of since you were 12
that's the wish fulfillment by the way
the frost punk was the strategy game i
was thinking of and the alters is the
new one that is very duncan jones it's
basically moon the strategy game which
is brilliant yeah yeah can i name drop
just real quick call back
uh because it's pursuant to your to your
point
um
david fincher has positioned himself
with have you met david fincher oh dave
oh you know dave adventure davey yeah
you
french i call him things um he uh he was
talking about how
you know he's obviously leveraged
himself well with with netflix
specifically
and they're like what do you want to
make
and he goes well i've got this story
about makowitz who you know
wrote citizen kane in the story of him
he was but i want to do a black and
white i want to record this sound in
mono and normally anybody else who would
have had that pitch they'd laugh they're
like sure whatever you want to do man
okay
all you got to do is put your name on
the marquee and it'll
get nominated for rosters so
i i really agree with that i don't think
there's anything wrong with blatantly
saying this is my love for this and i
want to make this
and so and that that goes for music as
well for me it's like i've always wanted
i was influenced by these albums and i
like some of the greatest albums that
i've i listened to or growing up
specifically were never recorded in a
studio so when it came time for me to do
an album i was like i don't want to go
to a traditional studio i want to do
what they did which was grab a shitload
of gear and go to some location
and like depeshmo did this radiohead did
this the beatles did this it's like
let's go somewhere else and record this
thing and turn this thing into a studio
and live there and eat there and breathe
there and that was when you went to big
bear
yeah and the second time we went up to
oh i thought that was a joke you did it
in big bear did it in big bear and
that's super cool we pulled up with all
of this gear and our the guy that was
the engineer goes did anybody check the
power in this place and we went uh-oh
i don't know if we have no power and he
literally spent two days hooking
everything up and on the last day he
goes this is the last patch cable's like
way to go he goes no no literally after
this i don't have any more like we can't
plug anything else in i have brought
just enough cables wow um but we you
know we did that for for four days and
the second time we did it for two weeks
and it's just
i i highly recommend that for anybody so
i don't think there's anything wrong
with saying no i think the imitation is
an absolutely valid stage in the
creative growth yeah or emulation
airbnbs what were you where were you
doing these things one of them was
airbnb and the other one is a studio
that is called panorama studios and it's
on uh
basically up by mount tamalpais in the
bay area
um and it is it the band of horses did
their last couple of records there my
morning jacket at the last couple of
records there and
it has accommodations yeah so you
can p some people just you know ran out
the house because you have these
beautiful panoramic views of the
mountains in the ocean
and they also have on this the the
ground floor
is the state-of-the-art studio with the
best analog gear you could possibly
imagine and so but it was like 500 bucks
a day it was nothing in a studio to rent
it's typically in los angeles it's like
yeah like capital is what 2500 bucks a
day so it was
without crew damn so it was incredibly
uh attainable to be able to do
um
is that just someone's pet project that
they're not
like the guy that used to be the head
editor of tape op magazine um which
would review
all this gear bought this place and turn
it into a studio and then specifically
in san francisco there was one big
producer i can't remember who it was who
moved in and said here's my rates for
the day because he wanted to make great
studios available to any musician
and so it cut the rates it's like why
would i go to anyone else when i could
go to his studio and get a better rate
uh and so san francisco is a great place
to go go to record music um
i have a million questions that i could
ask but i want to uh instead ask
so did anyone catch up on any of the
news over the last week is there
anything anybody has to any input
anything exciting the moment we hit
record uh
it uh it came across my twitter feed
that
the joker sequel
uh todd phillips will have lady gaga as
harley quinn is a musical
oh
oh because she's in it maybe that feels
like a joke someone made in a i mean
hollywood reporter is saying sources say
it's a musical i yeah but i mean not
that i not that we should put much stock
in that but for all we know that's is it
todd phillips directed the first one
like yeah for all we know that's his
thing he's been dreaming of doing all
this time and joker way to keep it on
the rails mike biffle thank you
so you but but that's a good explanation
right if that guy's like grew up like
watching singing in the rain every
saturday and he's like one day one day
i'll have enough cachet to do it because
i
one two and then the joker yeah that's
the road map i don't know what to say
there is because there's tears
stretched like
if you're watching
it no you got it you nailed it
this is what um this is what um
what rahul had said to me about mike
flanagan where he was like it was like
basically he was biting his time until
he could make midnight mass because that
was like there are tears there are tears
it's when when you when the whole dream
project our tears
yes
midnight mass shed many there are tears
of dreams there are tears of like there
is the thing you like i've had this
recently and i have to keep super vague
but like
volume was a game i really wanted to
make the kind of the self thing
and then i wanted to there are other
things i want to do that are more
expensive and stupider and i'm now
starting to get to a point where i can
start to talk people into maybe letting
me do that so it's
like mine are like i know that i
dream one was work at ign dream two was
work full time on a triple a game
now what do i do what what was the what
was the what was our like false
interpretation of mike's accent again
oscar waters oscar water
you you love that book though troy right
that was a very huge book do you love
that book i haven't even started it yet
oh okay
yeah i can't bounce between books well i
i if i do it's it's got to be you say
you were reading like five last week
yeah it started getting crazy because i
was i was reading like
i was doing like
stoicism it was just like
i was
getting confused
well mike it seems like you watch the
conferences wait wait well actually
a lot of you said it's a provocative
question though that i'm when you said
something like what do you how do i
oh what do i yeah i don't have a dream
that's you don't have a dream you don't
have a dream no
no come on you said you're living in the
tree you literally just said you want to
do it direct to horror game
uh make a horror game yeah but like it's
still like like the the bigger dream was
right on a triple a game full-time and
that's happening okay then i'm like
but what do you want to write like what
what you said majora's mask was like
i don't care and and maybe that's just
like the point that i'm at is that i
don't care what i write at all what i
care about is writing with people who
teach me to be a better writer so i
don't even [ __ ] when i write that's a
character
it also paired it up i care about
working with experienced
knowledgeable people that i will learn
from i don't care about if if any time
anyone's ever like what's your dream
video game if you could direct i'd be
like i would say no
instead i would pick a bunch of people
that are awesome to work with and i
would have them teach me how to do
something i it comes in waves though
like i think as well especially like as
you move through your career and and
maybe you know you're in this job maybe
you move into another job like where as
you as you continue on through your
career you're going to start having
touchstones where you're like
you're going to you're going to develop
new dreams based on your experience
you're going to go oh i really like that
thing about that job i'd love to do
worse out or i or i hated that thing
about that job i need to like move away
yeah there are definitely already things
that i'm like oh i really like this
particular aspect of this and would like
to do more of it but i don't feel like
they surpassed the dream of of work
full-time when writing triple a game i
think it's an and not an or because for
me it's like when i start seeing other
people make mistakes that i've seen
other people make or myself make before
and
knowing
the lessons that
that were learned from that experience
to go just just real quick
that that will shock you don't touch
that it's like oh and next thing you
know you find yourself in a position
going i don't know this
i'm not in charge or anything i just i
just know that i've learned from these
people that this is a better way to do
this but maybe maybe it works for you
maybe it doesn't
um i don't think it's an now i anybody
that that says is like i just i mean i
want to just want to direct i can't wait
to direct because this [ __ ] guy
she's terrible i'm like you are not
really correct ask me to direct i'd be
like why on earth would you ask me to do
that i don't [ __ ] know what's
happening god no i would i would
encourage you a lot
again as someone as someone who's kind
of gone through that journey like if
someone does ever you offer you an
opportunity like that you absolutely
should take it because you should take
so after thomas was alone so there are
in your career you will have cache it's
it it's weird how we're coalescing
around this specific theme of like
career you're welcome
like you like there will be moments
where you have more and less shine on
you and when you have the shine on you
so when when people are like interested
or excited they will give you these
opportunities i'm definitely when thomas
was alone blew up i definitely turned
down stuff with exactly the mindset
you're saying like i'm not ready for
that i'm not good enough for that i look
back now and i'm like i'd have muddled
through and i've learned some [ __ ] i've
treated you so i definitely did that
when i started out in journalism where i
didn't apply for things because i had
decided that i didn't have enough
experience but i realized that all the
other [ __ ] weren't thinking
that way
and thus i was just cheating myself out
of more professional experience but if
someone were to offer me a directing
role i would be like god no i will just
[ __ ] up all these other people's
lives when they're making that offer to
you you'll have done something they will
have more experience they'll still end
up directing but i suspect it would be
film and tv rather than if somebody says
great job or some people used to you
know
in a band or whatever come up and and uh
or anything that i did they'd be like oh
my god that was so great and there was
this feeling in me that i wanted to go
oh no and down playing oh and i was you
have no idea it was such a the sound was
terrible and oh i didn't think it was
great at all
huh i'm not trying to be humble i i hear
you but what are you saying you're
really appraising your skill set which
is totally reasonable i'm saying maybe
be a bit more stupid about it yes
yeah that's a that's a wonderful way to
say it tastly what you're saying if
someone says hey i believe i'm gonna be
first of all i'm in a position to be
able to give you this opportunity number
two if sony offered me a promotion i
would be like no no no no no we don't
need to do that what do you think we
don't need that
ten
not so good bloke stood next to you will
not say no to that job but then you'll
be working for those blokes so yeah what
would be that what would be the point in
turning down a promotion i get i get i
get the idea of the batteries i get
where she's coming from because i've 100
i feel like i'm i'm so benefited by the
position that i'm in right now that it's
nuts that they pay me like i just get to
work with super talented people who i
learn from constantly almost like a
student sometimes my notes but without
change that they've said that are
insightful yeah would you stop learning
me in a position of leadership i'd be
like
you'll always have people to learn from
that means that that you can only learn
in a subscription everything about
leadership is you have a bunch of people
who can teach you and they have to tell
you the answers to the question but if
somebody gives you an offer particularly
have also been burned by bad leadership
in video games be good leadership
that's true then demonstrate good
leadership if you've if you've had bad
leadership pull down the energy troy a
little bit you're a little i'm so
passionate about this just because they
failed at night for mike and he's trying
to wind down you're good you're good
i've already had a glass of water so
you've got to remember as well me and
alana didn't grow up in america so like
our frame framework for kind of the
american dream
but i also very much suspect being a
woman plays into it because i think that
women are less inclined to believe in
their abilities if they aren't proven
like case in point everybody telling me
i don't deserve my job every day i don't
think any junior writer who's a man has
had the experience we see it every day
in the interview process
we've just hired a bunch of people and
i've had to on interviews talk women
into off are looking for a job with us
100 likes
by the way i'm not saying that i'm in
the same position
sorry mike i didn't mean to talk over
you no you're all right i just want to
be first i don't i don't think that uh i
i'm equating myself with the plight of a
woman who's experienced what you're
talking about however i'm i'm simply
pointing out the fact that i get told on
a daily basis that i do not deserve the
opportunities that have been given to me
that i'm talentless but i'm tired
i knew i did
it
was gonna be one of us i'm glad it was
me
alana i here's why i want you it's it's
that classic thing of like but i can't
do this and i shouldn't do this you
should have the go that's exactly why it
has to go to you is [ __ ] people over
well here's the thing though
i don't think you inherently would [ __ ]
people over too exactly
who is giving you the opportunity and if
you if someone says i'm in a position
i'm going to give you an opportunity
you have to you don't have to i would
hope that for myself i would trust that
person i'm going to uh let's say neil
neil says to me is like hey man i want
you to direct something
i my relationship with him
warrants the trust for me to go
if you think i can do this then your
opinion is more important than my
screaming voices at me and secondly
there's no way you're going to put
yourself in a position you're going to
give me enough rope to hang myself and
when i do you're going to pull me back
you're going to dust me off and you're
going to put me back out there and i'm
going to learn so you're not going no
one who's going to give you a good
opportunity
is going to allow there's going to be
fail safes in place now a shitty person
can give you a shitty opportunity and
you're right you could
i i suppose [ __ ] somebody over
but that's you simply saying i just want
to learn is the best position for you to
come from and to be clear like i think
it's a reasonably articulated point of
lines making of like if you are in
leadership by definition you are going
to occasionally [ __ ] up so you are by
definition i don't have any project
management skills which i do not have i
should not be managing a project
three on to a [ __ ] call every week
you have project management there is
that also to be clearly also
project management i feel like there's
also a big difference just in practical
terms for a game director in project
management versus creative direction i
feel like though those are actually oh
well that's an episode like
i feel like i feel like you're you're
going higher well you're going i don't
know how to kind of
make sure all the nuts and bolts are in
the right place and i guess producers
can just say that doesn't actually sound
like you need both you do produce
you also need a pragmatic understanding
of that stuff but to be honest i'm not
dismissing that i just think that's a
thing that's done in tandem with people
who like this is where
the people that are responsible for
those nuts and bolts are going to be the
partners in ensuring that all that is in
place and that the creative vision that
helps drive it all is
um
would seemingly necessarily be the top
priority of one's
but i i what i'm saying is i don't think
i think we should be careful not to be
dismissive of alana's kind of
perspective that not being dismissive at
all i am no no no sorry probably she's
not not that i don't mean that the there
is a really it's something that i think
people massively underestimate until
they are leading like god how many
people report to me now it's like 15 odd
which is still small by industry
standards
salaries lives it's a lot of weight on
your shoulders and if you're someone who
is compassionate and cares about the
people who work for you which you know
you should be in that job but often
that's not the case look i've managed
people before but it was in journalism
which i like know like the back of my
hand exactly so it's okay
if somebody were to offer me a position
directing a video game
i think the point is there's no universe
in which that happens now exactly at the
point where maybe that would happen then
yes maybe i would be experienced and it
might be a year earlier than you think
but hopefully as troy said the person
doing the offering you will trust enough
to to go for it and believe in their
believe in their view of you yeah it's
true and that's probably a thing that i
have been very bad at in the past where
i've been like but i'm not ready and
like you said there were a lot of dudes
who had less experience who were ready
that's every [ __ ] manager you ever had
they just said yes to that question when
they do i um i have two thoughts because
one was basically that exact thing you
just ended with where i talked to a lot
of young composers
literally earlier today was
you know reading on a on discord
somebody said they shared some of their
music and they said this is um
where i feel like i'm at but it was it
was knowingly emulating another composer
and they said i don't feel like i'm
ready to
experiment and make my own thing yet uh
and and i remember thinking i asked them
and then i i haven't had a chance to
read their response because i've been
busy since i typed this but my question
was what would be the thing that then
catalyzes you feeling ready because the
universe is never going to show up with
a certificate that says you are now
ready to grow as an artist like that
must be self-propelled and so i i often
find people
who
are
like their heart is in the right place
of of what you're just saying i don't
want to put myself in a position to
you know make a bad game or to screw
over people who would be working for me
or whatever but but at the same time
from my experience nothing will ever
actually validate
um
that you are now ready that was thought
number one it's true when are you ready
yeah yeah like you you're ready when you
need to be and yeah you're ready exactly
you're always
you're you you will never feel qualified
until the opportunity lands you sign the
thing you [ __ ] a brick and then you
start making phone calls to the people
that can help you uh yeah that's the
main thing yeah like i remember one of
my one of my professors
uh it was a sort of a mentor composer
chris young who who did like a few sam
raimi films dragged me to hell
spider-man 3 he did the original like
hellraiser and
uh done a lot it's done a zillion movies
including a lot of horror films they did
the grudge and and
anyway chris wonderful lovely guy and he
always would say to his students like if
you land a job that you feel like you're
not ready for
um take the job do whatever it takes to
convince them you are ready and then as
soon as you get off the phone then call
me and we can step through it and figure
out how i can i can i can i can help you
and it was such a to bring it back again
duncan our mate mate of the doe show
duncan his dad david bowie he's got the
whole quote of um what's his name um
that's in order to swim you have to walk
out further than your feet touch the
ground right yeah in order to exercise
the water's just it's just that that's
the way you're pushing it how i do
things i always do things very slowly
and like grab it like when i was trying
to make sure that i had experience to
write a video game i don't know if i
ever told you guys this i was doing
game jams under a different name so
people didn't know it was me because i
didn't want to have anything under the
name whatsoever
exactly
so i did a ton of them just to like kind
of get like some insight to production
experience and then otherwise i was
asking studios that i knew if i could
sit in on their writers rooms and four
of them let me which was awesome
um and then was
doing a little bit of contract work for
one game that i'll eventually be able to
announce that people know that's cool
but i can't talk about it yet but it was
very very very very slow like that was
probably three years of just like a
little bit and then a little bit more
and then a little bit more and a tiny
bit more but i had also like finished
screenplays and it was able to submit
those too well and there's no
i don't think there's any universal
standard of how fast one ought to go i'm
simply
arguing like that's i have no objection
or or commentary on anything you just
said other than that
that
in the from the most zoomed out
perspective nothing will ever tell us
we're ready the other the other little
thing i wanted to throw in there that
you made me think of with what you were
saying troy in terms of
like the different director types
um
was you gave me a flashback to when i
was a student scoring a lot of student
games and you get these really
exaggerated versions of director
personalities when they're all students
because everybody's neurotic and
self-conscious and super afraid and
and but also
wildly arrogant with unearned
hubris like i love that about students i
admire that so much it's the worst i
remember this one yeah
i did a lot of student films like well
over a hundred and this one director
i'll never forget you know they all
first off the the good directors made
bad films the bad directors made bad
films like student films are just as a
general rule not good because you're
learning that's the point yeah like
they're they're the the goal is to screw
up in a low stakes environment it was
the same i wrote i'm sure endless
amounts of crap music for them as well
but i remember in particular
uh this director he was such an arrogant
prick and he was like he kept going you
know it's really important he was
interviewing composers for his
four-minute movie and he goes
it's very important to me
that you bring everything that you've
got to this project because this is
my entry into the business like this
people will notice and it was such this
please serve my needs oh and it was also
like don't don't be
he never asked me like i get that he's
afraid that he's gonna bring someone on
that now he's dependent on and then the
thing turns out badly and it was beyond
his control i think that the most
charitable read is that that was a
twisted distorted manifestation of that
kind of neurotic fear which is
understandable it's also not his entry
into the industry that's not how it
works
well exactly i was like the the best
director who's not ready for this
leadership role the first thing would
have been
like and i've heard this and most of the
best directors that i've worked with
over the years this is how the
conversation often starts
i don't know anything about music so
how do we get on the same page what can
i offer you that will let you
communicate and vice versa and it's
always questions and it's always like
how can i arm you with how to make this
best how do you work best do you want a
lot of feedback do you want to wait like
they they're just loaded with questions
and ready to kind of adapt and usually
i'm like neonatal our first conversation
was that was like that i think that's
yeah that's not requiring myself to the
best directors but i think that was as
best director
[Music]
was he wearing a shirt did you see his
abs in this process he was wearing a
shirt she's very sweet
very very sweet very probably in a very
good mood because he was at his
daughter's red carpet so it's like a
very special occasion
hell yeah yeah and he he basically just
kept thanking rahul he just was like
thank you so much for having her back
thank you so much for doing this it was
just so endearing it was so [ __ ]
sweet but i asked molly uh molly elfman
danny's daughter
about the the film's called next exit
just premiered at tribeca
um and it's her first short film and i
just asked her i was like i think that i
want to slowly do more directing uh and
it would be short films and and whatever
with people that i like and i was like
what's the biggest piece of advice that
you have
and she
she like one of the things that she said
was don't be afraid to fire people which
i was like that's very interesting
advice she was like if anybody is
challenging you in a way or anyone else
in a way that isn't
like creating a good team you can put so
much work into trying to resolve
conflicts that it would have been faster
for you to just hire someone else it's
like i never would have thought of that
because i'm absolutely a resolution
person i'd be like let's work through
this because i see a resolution if i
need to fire someone's not a good match
yeah you could just [ __ ] fire someone
that's like a very good piece of advice
the other one was
um like if you can as equally passionate
about creation as what you are like it's
that's a difficult thing to do but like
it's not necessarily higher people who
desperately need the job and you can
usually tell like hi people who care
about what you're making and take the
time to do that slowly before you make
something i would add on to that
hire people that are smarter more
experienced more passionate than you i
as the director
i want to be
you you can't lead from behind
um and typically fear has always put me
in a place of behind i'm hiding behind
other people are waiting
but you need to i as a director i need
to be out in front and and being like
hey if this fails it's great but no
typically nobody knows if you made a
mistake until you go i just made a
mistake
just keep shooting just keep shooting
it's like all right that works let me
try this again
it's always when people go
when you
whenever i've seen a director dig their
heels into a bad choice because they're
too afraid to admit that they made a
mistake
or to defend the mistake that they just
made that's what it's like now you just
showed your ass a little bit
um
i i need to jump onto my next thing i
was over here getting my next session
get my head stitched back get your head
stitched together as a point of order
that film of molly's is a feature not a
short um
oh yes it is but she had uh experience
mostly
it's her debut feature yeah yeah so i
think she made like over a hundred
shorts i think she'd say i'm not sure if
that that's true or
whatever but she was she was wonderful
and um nearly alone
yeah that's a whole lot bottom line
stitch back up other people have to work
i'm going to take any any director roles
any of you throw at me we believe i'm
ready
in the comments if you've got any direct
role for aladdin please let us know in
the comments
maybe one day i do think that's where
i'll end up i feel like i go narrative
design first and then i maybe direct
stuff one day but i just want to say if
anyone's ever making silent hill
just hit me up
i feel like five people are making
silent hill there's five people that are
making silent houses so many silent
hills just let me know if you need some
writing
you have great like narrative direction
and design like mentors right that you
kind of get feedback from and stuff
yeah again
i almost feel like my job is i'm at
university and i should be paying them
it's nuts so often i'm like why am i
getting paid for all of this information
you keep giving me i will take notes on
the things that they say that i'm
learning from
and not just the things i need to about
the game it's there yeah the team i work
with is just so world-class it's such a
privilege to get to work through keep
that don't lose it and they're all
wonderful and like like i think i said
this on the show before sometimes i'll
get an email with some terminology i
don't understand that some game dev [ __ ]
and i will ask
i know you're busy what does this mean
and i've never had anybody do anything
other than be like awesome that you
asked here's what this thing is
with a ton of enthusiasm like it's it's
so
cool to get to work with people who are
like just such absolute experts at what
they do and just have access to all of
them it's like 600 of them it's
incredible anyway this is play which
listen i'm a lot of peers i'm a video
game writer that's awesome winter music
video
we will see gameplay next week